This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1960, a new wonder drug hit the US market. And while a lot of new drugs promised dramatic results, this one would actually transform millions of lives and radically shift American culture. It was called a Noved. It was the first oral contraceptive. Drugs, for many, seem the answer to all the problems. When a government agency approves the first birth control pill in 1960, it helps set in motion forces
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1960年，一种全新的奇迹药物登陆美国市场。虽然许多新药都承诺能带来显著疗效，但这款药实际上将改变数百万人的生活，并从根本上重塑美国文化。它被称为 Noved。这是第一种口服避孕药。对许多人来说，药物似乎是所有问题的答案。当政府机构在1960年批准第一种避孕药时，它有助于推动一股力量
that will soon change the social morays of the world. In just two years, 1.2 million American women were taking the birth control pill. That's reporter Lila Turnif. Within five years, the pill would become the most popular form of birth control in the country. It let women choose if and when they wanted to have children. It gave them more freedom to pursue careers.
这股力量很快将改变世界的社会风气。仅仅两年时间，就有120万美国女性在服用避孕药。这是记者莉拉·特尼夫说的。在五年内，避孕药将成为该国最受欢迎的避孕方式。它让女性能够自主选择是否以及何时生育子女。它赋予了她们更多追求职业发展的自由。
And it helped usher in the free love era of the late 1960s. It was a big deal. And even if you've never taken the pill, you can probably picture its packaging. There's the round plastic package that opens like a shell and looks kind of like a makeup compact. There's also the more low-key rectangular pill sheets with each pill arranged in four neat rows for every day of the month. It's hard to think of other prescription drug packages that are as widely recognizable as those of the birth control pill. But the pill didn't always have special packaging.
它还催生了20世纪60年代末的自由恋爱时代。这是一件大事。即使你从未服用过避孕药，你也可能在脑海中浮现出它的包装。有那种像贝壳一样打开、看起来有点像化妆粉盒的圆形塑料包装。还有那种更低调的长方形药板，每粒药整齐地排列成四行，对应一个月的每一天。很难想到还有哪种处方药包装能像避孕药那样具有如此高的辨识度。但避孕药并非一开始就有特殊的包装。
The first birth control pill to hit the market came in a simple glass bottle of loose tablets, like any other prescription drug. They come in big bottles for a year's supply. Smaller bottles for a month's supply and hand. As the pill went from nondescript bottles to the iconic pill packages, it came to represent larger trends in American medicine.
第一款上市的避孕药装在装有散装药片的简单玻璃瓶里，就像任何其他处方药一样。它们装在供一年使用的大瓶子里。也有供一个月使用的较小瓶子。随着避孕药从平淡无奇的瓶子转变为标志性的药丸包装，它开始代表美国医学领域的更大趋势。
Women were beginning to take more control of their own bodies, and their demands for a new standard of patient autonomy would go on to affect prescription packaging of all kinds. It all started with a family in Illinois. In 1961, David and Doris Wagner were a middle-aged couple with four kids. They didn't want any more of them, and so they were thrilled to learn about the pill. Doris got a prescription. The pills came in a big bottle. The instruction said to begin the pill on the fifth day of her period, and to take one pill every day for 20 days, followed by a five-day break for menstruation.
女性开始对自己的身体拥有更多的控制权，她们对新型患者自主权标准的要求，将继续影响各种处方药的包装。这一切都始于伊利诺伊州的一个家庭。1961年，大卫和多丽丝·瓦格纳是一对育有四个孩子的中年夫妇。他们不想再生育了，因此得知避孕药的消息时，他们兴奋不已。多丽丝拿到了一张处方。药装在一个大瓶子里。说明书上说，要在月经开始的第五天服药，连续20天每天服药一粒，然后停药五天用于行经。
If Doris lost track of her cycle, or if she forgot whether or not she had taken her pill that day, she was instructed to pour all the pills out of the bottle, count how many pills were left, subtract that from the original number of pills, and consult a calendar, not as super user-friendly design. And if she missed a pill, she risk getting pregnant again. So David Wagner noticed that his wife, Adoris, was often sort of concerned about taking her pills, and he was also concerned about whether or not she was taking her pills. The Wagner's have since passed away, but this is Carolyn Eiser, a women's health expert who has researched the Wagner's and their role in the history of birth control packaging. So he thought, hmm, not why don't I do something about this?
如果多丽丝记不清自己的生理周期，或者忘记那天是否已经服药，说明书上的做法是把瓶子里所有的药都倒出来，数一数还剩多少粒，用最初的总数减去这个数字，然后查看日历——这可不是什么超用户友好的设计。如果她漏服了一片，就有再次怀孕的风险。因此，大卫·瓦格纳注意到他的妻子多丽丝经常对服药感到有些担忧，而他自己也很关心她到底有没有按时服药。瓦格纳夫妇现在都已经去世了，这位是卡罗琳·艾瑟，她是一位女性健康专家，曾对瓦格纳夫妇及其在避孕药包装史上的角色进行过研究。于是他想，嗯，为什么我不做点什么来改变现状呢？
David Wagner was an engineer for a tool company in Illinois, and he was used to solving mechanical problems. He figured he could create a packaging system that would make the pill-taking process easier for his wife. First he tried something really simple. He took a piece of paper and he wrote out the days of the week and put the pills on the piece of paper along with the days of the week to sort of make it into a bit of a calendar. And that worked pretty well, at least for a few weeks. Then I guess the story goes, something fell on the dresser and the pills, got scattered
大卫·瓦格纳是伊利诺伊州一家工具公司的工程师，他习惯于解决机械问题。他觉得，自己可以创造一套包装系统，让妻子服药的过程变得更轻松。首先，他尝试了一种非常简单的方法。他拿了一张纸，在上面写下星期几，然后把药片和星期几放在纸上，这样基本上就把纸变成了一个简易日历。这方法挺管用的，至少管用了几个星期。然后故事的发展大概是这样的：有什么东西掉在了梳妆台上，药片散落开来
and fell on the floor, and that was that, that made him think. Maybe I can make a package that, say, you could throw in your purse, throw in your bag, take with you, and it would keep everything in order. So what he came up with is today very familiar to anyone who's probably used the birth control pill. Diane went as a curator of the extensive birth control archive at the Smithsonian Museum of American History. And we actually have some of the prototypes over here. Widener's original prototype was made out of two discs of clear plastic and a snap fastener that he borrowed from a child's toy. The bottom disc held 20 pills.
掉到了地板上，事情就这样发生了，这让他陷入了沉思。也许我可以做一个包装，比如你可以把它扔进钱包、扔进包里、随身携带，而且它能把所有东西都整理得井井有条。因此，他想出的设计对于任何用过避孕药的人来说都非常熟悉。黛安·温特是史密森尼美国历史博物馆庞大避孕档案的馆藏负责人。我们实际上这里就保存了一些原型。维德纳最初的原型是用两片透明塑料圆盘和一个从儿童玩具上借来的按扣制成的。底部的圆盘装有20粒药片。
The top disc had one hole drilled through it, which could be rotated each day to expose the correct pill along with the course Monday and Day of the Week. Having this system that made pill taking more intuitive helped do our some David feel a lot more comfortable. This is David Wagner writing in, let's say, January 16, 1995. This is a letter Wagner sent to Smithsonian Museum for their birth control archive.
顶部的圆盘上钻了一个孔，每天可以旋转这个孔，以便露出正确的那粒药，同时还有对应的星期。拥有这个让服药更直观的系统，让大卫感到非常欣慰。这是大卫·瓦格纳在1995年1月16日左右写下的记录。这是瓦格纳寄给史密森尼博物馆用于其避孕档案的一封信。
Both Doris and I could tell it a glance whether a pill had been taken on a given day. This did wonders for our relationship. Wagner successfully received a patent for his design, Wagner successfully received a patent for his design, but he had trouble convincing pharmaceutical companies to get on board. He actually took it around to some of the big companies, and most of them said sort of things like, well, we don't need that. That's kind of gimmicky and everything. At the time, drug companies were known for the boring sameness of their prescription packaging. Wagner was told that a special package just for
多丽丝和我一眼就能看出在特定的一天是否已经服过药。这对我们的关系产生了奇妙的影响。瓦格纳成功为他的设计申请了专利，瓦格纳成功为他的设计申请了专利，但他很难说服制药公司接受这个想法。他实际上拿着它去拜访了一些大公司，他们大部分人的反应基本上都是：“我们不需要这个。这有点像个噱头，而且没什么用。”在当时，制药公司以其处方药包装的沉闷和千篇一律而闻名。有人告诉瓦格纳，专门为
birth control sounded kind of commercial and flashy. His design was turned down by every company he approached. But then just a few months later, one of the companies he'd met with, called Ortho Pharmaceuticals, released their first birth control pill. And these pills came in a circular plastic container with a dial that moved each day to reveal the next pill. It was called the dial pack. To David Wagner, the dial pack looked very familiar. Maybe a little too familiar. Wagner threatened a lawsuit. In December of 1964, he signed an agreement with orthopharmaceuticals for $10,000 and a promise not to sue. Another company called SIRL soon began
避孕药设计的特殊包装听起来未免太商业化、太花哨了。他接触的每一家公司都拒绝了他的设计。然而就在几个月后，他拜访过的一家名为奥尔索制药的公司推出了他们的第一款避孕药。这些药装在一个圆形的塑料容器里，带有一个每天拨动以显示下一粒药的转盘。它被称为转盘包装（dial pack）。在大卫·瓦格纳看来，这个转盘包装非常眼熟。也许眼熟得过头了。瓦格纳威胁要提起诉讼。1964年12月，他与奥尔索制药公司签署了一项协议，获得了1万美元的赔偿并承诺不予起诉。另一家名为塞尔的药物公司不久也开始
paying Wagner royalties for the rights to produce a similar pill container. And pretty soon, all birth control manufacturers were coming out with a version of this circular design. Here's Diane went again, reading from the letter Wagner wrote to the Smithsonian. He said some people have wondered how I made out financially. I spent about $30 on the six models I made in my basement
向瓦格纳支付专利使用费，以获得生产类似药盒的权利。很快，所有避孕药制造商都推出了这种圆形设计的版本。这里又是黛安·温特，她正在宣读瓦格纳写给史密森尼博物馆的信。他说，有些人想知道我在财务上过得怎么样。我在地下室制作的六个模型上花大约花了30美元
and the rest of my cost for legal fees over the life of the patent. He says he netted about 100,000 in royalties. Eventually, David Wagner got tired of chasing royalty obligations from pharmaceutical companies, and he sold the patent rights to orthopharmaceuticals. He returned to his quiet life in Illinois, but his design became a national sensation. As pharmaceutical companies began marketing these new birth control pills, they faced
其余的成本是在专利生命周期内的律师费。他说他净赚了大约10万美元的专利费。最终，大卫·瓦格纳厌倦了追讨制药公司的专利使用费，他将专利权卖给了奥尔索制药公司。他回到了伊利诺伊州平静的生活中，但他的设计却成了轰动全国的爆款。随着制药公司开始推销这些新型避孕药，他们面临着
a couple obstacles. Obstacles that the packaging design would help overcome. First of all, the pill marked a big turning point in the pharmaceutical industry. Before birth control, only sick people took pharmaceutical drugs. The birth control pill was one of the first prescriptions intended to be taken by healthy Americans. And so, pharmaceutical companies designed the packaging to look not like medicine, but instead like an ordinary everyday object. They began packaging the pills and circular plastic cases
几个障碍。包装设计将有助于克服这些障碍。首先，避孕药标志着制药行业的一个巨大转折点。在避孕药出现之前，只有病人才会服用处方药。避孕药是第一批旨在供健康的美国人服用的处方药之一。因此，制药公司将包装设计得不像药品，而更像是普通的日常用品。他们开始将药片装在圆形的塑料盒里
that looked a lot like makeup compacts. They were decorated with bright colors and graphics. I would say flowers and butterflies are probably the most common on them. I was kind of wonder about that why they didn't get a little more edgies at least at times. From a suitable companies also experimented with packaging gimmicks
看起来非常像化妆粉盒。它们用鲜艳的色彩和图案进行装饰。我要说的是，花朵和蝴蝶可能是上面最常见的图案。我有时会琢磨，为什么他们不把设计搞得再前卫一点呢，至少在某些时候是这样。适合的公司还尝试了各种包装噱头
to make daily pill taking seem normal and unremarkable. One pill company went so far as to bundle a toothbrush and a bar of soap with each prescription. You know, brush your teeth, wash your face, take your pill, it's kind of, you know, another part of a daily routine. The other challenge that pharmaceutical companies faced as they rolled out this groundbreaking new medication was the conservative outlook of some doctors. In the 1960s, doctors were overwhelmingly male and some were wary about the revolutionary impact the birth control pill would have on sex and general roles.
为了让每日服药看起来正常且毫不起眼。有一家制药公司甚至走得更远，在每份处方中捆绑了一支牙刷和一块香皂。你知道的，刷牙、洗脸、吃药，这有点像你日常生活中的另一个部分。制药公司在推出这款具有划时代意义的新药时面临的另一个挑战是某些医生保守的观点。在20世纪60年代，医生绝大多数是男性，其中一些人对避孕药将对性观念和性别角色产生的革命性影响感到警惕。
The subject for this afternoon's continuing discussion of the pill is the power to prescribe. In 1967, a group of doctors gathered in San Francisco at a symposium called the Pill and the Puritan Ethic, where they explored the moral implications of the birth control pill. Here's Dr. Donald Minkler, a leader in women's health and family planning, describing the challenges the pill presented for physicians who might be uncomfortable with changing attitudes
今天下午关于避孕药的持续讨论的主题是处方权。1967年，一群医生聚集在旧金山，参加一个名为“避孕药与清教徒伦理”的研讨会，他们在会上探讨了避孕药的道德含义。这位是女性健康和计划生育领域的领袖唐纳德·明克勒医生，他正在描述避孕药给那些可能对日渐改变的态度感到不自在的医生带来的挑战
towards primarital sacs. How can he maintain his emotional neutrality in the face of rapidly changing values among his younger patients whose code of conduct often will differ markedly from his own? The ethical dilemmas posed by the demand and the obvious need for contraceptive advice among the young and unmarried has generated a good deal of anxiety and discomfort in the minds of physicians. Not only were physicians grappling with stuff that was actually not their business, they
面对年轻患者中瞬息万变的价值观，他的行为准则往往与他自己有着明显的差异，在这种情况下，他该如何保持情感上的中立？年轻且未婚人群对避孕建议的需求以及显而易见的需求所带来的道德困境，在医生心中引发了相当大的焦虑和不安。医生们不仅在管那些实际上不关他们事的事情，他们
also thought that some of their young female patients might not even be responsible enough to manage their daily pill-taking regimen. Here's another doctor at the symposium, Dr. Albert Long. The girl who can't remember to take her pill every morning is in trouble, and this is one of the problems with the pill. We have to have a patient who will understand how it is used, use it correctly. Pharmaceutical companies needed to market the pill to skeptical doctors who might not be totally comfortable with the idea of women taking control of their reproductive health.
还认为他们的一些年轻女性患者甚至没有足够的责任感来管理她们每日服药的疗程。这里是研讨会上的另一位医生，阿尔伯特·ロング医生。那个记不清每天早晨吃药的女孩就麻烦了，这就是避孕药的问题之一。我们必须拥有一个能够理解它是如何使用并正确使用它的患者。制药公司需要向那些可能对女性掌控自身生殖健康这一想法感到不太自在的持怀疑态度的医生推销避孕药。
And once again, they used the pill's packaging to help them do that. Pharmaceutical companies produce dozens of ads that targeted physicians. They marketed the new pill packages as a way to help female patients take the pills correctly. They advertise the device as the package that remembers for her or the foolproof method. Each company insisted their pill package design would help the female patients stay on schedule. Which was true, the packaging did help women stay on schedule. But the marketing of these so-called compliance packages played into some doctors' struggles for control at a time when their cultural authority was weakening.
而这一次，他们再次利用避孕药的包装来帮助他们做到这一点。制药公司制作了数十个针对医生的广告。他们将新型药盒作为帮助女性患者正确服药的一种方式进行营销。他们将该装置宣传为“会替她记住的包装”或“万无一失的方法”。每家公司都坚信，他们的药盒设计将有助于女性患者按时服药。这确实是真的，包装确实帮助女性按时服药。但是，对这些所谓的依从性包装的营销，迎合了一些医生在自身文化权威日渐式微之际对控制权的争夺。
Here's medical historian Dominique Tobel. Prior to the introduction of oral contraceptives, the image of the physician-patient relationship is really one in which patients, whether male or female, would really kind of just do what the physician said. It was like this period of medical paternalism that physician knows best. With the introduction of the pill, the idea that a woman would go to the doctor's office and demand a particular prescription, that was something that was quite new. As the 60s progressed, more and more women began taking the pill. And a series of Supreme court cases also helped establish that women, both unmarried and married, had a legal right
这里是医学历史学家多米尼克·托贝尔。在口服避孕药问世之前，医生与患者关系的形象实际上是这样的：患者（无论是男是女）基本上只是照着医生说的去做。这就像是医学家长制作风的时期，即“医生最懂”。随着避孕药的引入，女性去医生办公室要求开某种特定处方药的这种想法，是一件相当新鲜的事情。随着20世纪60年代的推进，越来越多的女性开始服用避孕药。一系列最高法院的判决也有助于确立女性（无论是未婚还是已婚）拥有获得避孕药物的法律权利
to contraceptive medications. The invention of the pill and the subsequent legal victories were hailed as feminist milestones, but there was a darker side to the pill, too. In this darker side, it would lead to one more major revolution in pharmaceutical packaging. The pill of the 1960s is not the same pill we have today. The old pill had about seven times more estrogen, and this high dose of estrogen causes some negative side effects, like dizziness and nausea, as well as more serious problems like blood clots and high risk of cancer.
避孕药的发明和随后的法律胜利被誉为女性主义的里程碑，但避孕药也有其阴暗面。正是这个阴暗面，将引发制药包装领域的又一次重大革命。20世纪60年代的避孕药与我们今天的避孕药并不完全相同。旧版避孕药的雌激素含量大约是现在的七倍，而高剂量的雌激素会导致一些负面副作用，比如头晕和恶心，以及血栓和高癌症风险等更严重的问题。
Some of these problems had been apparent in early birth control trials, that the trials had been conducted in the 1950s in Puerto Rico, where the pill was primarily tested on low income women, many of whom were not even aware they were participating in a medical trial. Researchers mostly ignored their complaints. As the pill moved into the mainstream, most women did not hear about these health risks from their doctors, and it was hard to fathom that the pill that came in pink plastic compacts, the pill that millions of women carried around in their purses, that those pills could be dangerous. Then in 1969, a book was published.
其中一些问题在早期的避孕试验中就已经显现出来，这些试验于20世纪50年代在波多黎各进行，当时的避孕药主要是在低收入女性身上进行测试，其中许多人甚至不知道自己正在参加一项医学试验。研究人员基本上忽视了她们的抱怨。随着避孕药进入主流，大多数女性并没有从医生那里听说过这些健康风险，而且很难想象装在粉红色塑料粉盒里的避孕药、千百万女性随身携带在钱包里的避孕药，竟然会有危险。然后，在1969年，一本书出版了。
Barbara Seaman, who was a journalist at the time, wrote the doctor's case against the pill, which documented what she, another's belief, was really kind of a kind of a gregious treatment by drug companies and physicians and the FDA, the failure to kind of acknowledge these serious risks around the pill. As women learned about these risks, they got angry. Most didn't want the pill to be taken off the market. But they did want more transparency about the side effects. In 1970, Barbara Seaman's book inspired Congress to hold hearings to investigate the safety of the birth control pill, but no women were invited to testify at these hearings.
芭芭拉·西曼当时是一名记者，她写了《医生的避孕药案》（The Doctor's Case Against the Pill），记录了她和另一些人所认为的制药公司、医生以及FDA一种极其恶劣的对待方式，即未能承认围绕避孕药的这些严重风险。当女性了解到这些风险时，她们愤怒了。大多数人并不希望避孕药退市。但她们确实希望对副作用有更高的透明度。1970年，芭芭拉·西曼的书激发国会举行听证会，以调查避孕药的安全性，但没有女性被邀请在这些听证会上作证。
It was a panel of men, white men. And this, not surprisingly, was really alarming to Simon and other feminists at that time. And so they protested at those hearings and demanded that their voice be heard about the pill. Each morning of the hearings, a group of women from the activist group, DC Women's Liberation, convened at the Capitol with prepared questions and bail money tucked into their socks.
这是一个由男性、白人男性组成的专家小组。毫无疑问，这让西曼当时的女性主义者感到非常震惊。因此，她们在听证会上进行抗议，要求发出关于避孕药的声音。听证会每天早晨，来自激进团体“华盛顿特区妇女解放运动”的一群女性都会聚集在国会山，带着准备好的问题和塞在袜子里的保释金。
The women strategically placed themselves in the middle of audience rows and repeatedly interrupted the hearings demanding more transparency. Why have you assured the drug companies that they can testify? Why have you told them they will get top priority? They're not taking the pills, we are.
这些女性巧妙地把自己安排在观众席中间的排里，不断打断听证会，要求更高的透明度。为什么你们向制药公司保证他们可以作证？为什么你们告诉他们会享有最高优先级？不是他们在吃药，是我们。
Uh-huh. It was really remarkable show of activism and kind of showcasing the paternalism of medicine at that time. We are not going to say, quiet, we're heading longer. You are murdering us for your profit and convenience. I'm not going to permit the proceedings to be interrupted in this way.
嗯哼。这真是一场非同寻常的激进行动，展示了当时医学界的家长制作风。我们绝不会闭嘴，我们不会再忍气吞声了。为了你们的利润和便利，你们正在谋杀我们。我绝不允许诉讼程序以这种方式被打断。
A few ladies would have been interrupted by taking this pill. We're conducting, I don't think the hearings are anymore. We're going to be in their lives. These hearings revealed that some doctors had long been aware of the negative side effects of the pill, and many had failed to adequately alert their female patients. The situation left many women feeling torn. They were grateful for the freedom and autonomy
有些女士在服用这种避孕药时被打断了。我们正在进行，我觉得听证会已经不再进行了。我们将进入她们的生活。这些听证会表明，一些医生长期以来一直知道避孕药的负面副作用，但许多人未能充分提醒他们的女性患者。这种情况让许多女性感到痛苦和纠结。她们对避孕药带给她们的自由和自主权心存感激
the pill gave them, but they also felt betrayed by the doctors and pharmaceutical companies that had failed to warn them about the possible risks. At this point, the pill had been on the market for nearly a decade. intimidation by white-coated guards, antiseptically directing our lives. I mean, this really had a different kind of transformative impact on the physician-patient relationship, because the health risks around the birth control pill, these really raised the issue of, like,
但她们也感到被那些未能警告她们注意潜在风险的医生和制药公司背叛了。此时，避孕药已经上市近十年了。受到身穿白大褂的守卫的恐吓，消毒水般地引导着我们的生活。我的意思是，这确实对医生与患者的关系产生了另一种变革性的影响，因为围绕避孕药的健康风险，这些确实提出了这样一个问题：
does the physician know best? Do they know best and do they act in the best interests of patients? Do they know best and do they act in the best interests of patients? Over the years the hormonal dosage of the pill was gradually lowered and it became much safer for women Although there are still some negative side effects You know the longer longer term legacy is that you know now we have a health care environment in which patients, pharmaceutical consumers, are really much more willing to raise questions and raise concerns. The scandal also led to one more enduring innovation in pill packaging.
难道医生最懂吗？他们真的最懂，并且是在为患者的最佳利益行事吗？他们真的最懂，并且是在为患者的最佳利益行事吗？多年来，避孕药的激素剂量逐渐降低，对女性来说安全多了，尽管仍然存在一些负面副作用。你知道的，更长远的遗产是，现在我们拥有这样一个医疗保健环境：患者、药物消费者真的更愿意提出问题和疑虑。这起丑闻还催生了药品包装领域的又一项持久创新。
Feminist health activists successfully changed FDA policy to require a typed warning of side effects to be included in every birth control package. This laid the groundwork for the side effects warnings that come in all prescription packages today. So today when you pick up a prescription, any prescription, that little typed sheet you get that lists every side effect from the mild to the terrifying, you have birth control to thank for that. Of course, these inserts present their own design challenges. If you've ever tried to read one, you're familiar with the tiny font, the medical jargon,
女性主义健康活动家成功改变了FDA的政策，要求每个避孕药包装中都必须包含一份打印出来的副作用警告。这为当今所有处方药包装中附带的副作用警告奠定了基础。因此，今天当你去取处方药时——任何处方药——你拿到的那张列出了从轻微到可怕的所有副作用的小打印纸，你得感谢避孕药带来了这一切。当然，这些说明书本身也带来了设计挑战。如果你曾试图阅读过其中一份，你就会对密密麻麻的小字、医学术语
and the completely overwhelming amount of information. Common birth control set of X include inter-mensual spotting, nausea, breast hernets, headaches, weight gain, mood changes, misperiods, herzotism, decreased libido. Let's hope there's a good designer out there to make sense of all that information for us. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Lila Terniff with The Lanye Hall, mixed in tech production by Shereefusif, music by Sean Reale, Melodium, and Ok Okumi. Our senior producer is Katie Mingle. Kurt Colstead is the digital director.
以及完全让人应接不暇的海量信息感到熟悉。常见的避孕药副作用包括月经间期点滴出血、恶心、乳房触痛、头痛、体重增加、情绪变化、月经推迟、多毛症、性欲减退。希望外面能有一个优秀的设计师，能为我们把所有这些信息梳理清楚。本周的 99% Invisible 由莉拉·特尼夫与兰伊·霍尔制作，谢里夫·尤瑟夫负责混音和技术制作，音乐由肖恩·里尔、梅洛迪姆和奥克·奥库米创作。我们的高级制作人是凯蒂·明格尔。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。
The rest of the staff includes Avery Truffleman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Terran Mousa, and me Ronan Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We'll on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But we have new articles by Kate Wagner of Mangan Hell and our own Kurt Colstad on our
其余的工作人员包括艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德、特兰·穆萨以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个节目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心电台街。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars，也可以@节目 @99PI org。我们也在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上。我们在网站上刊登了来自 Mangan Hell 的凯特·瓦格纳以及我们自己的库尔特·科尔斯特德撰写的新文章。
website. That's 99PI.org. Radio Tapio. from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 99PI.org。Radio Tapio，来自 PRX。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。